Speaker 1: The Biden Department of Justice
is making a risky political move in arguing
and appealing the Florida judge's decision
about masks on planes, and if this fails to
work, this could jeopardize the ability of
the CDC and other agencies to ever require
masking or other public health guidelines
on public transportation.
If it fails, so it is very politically risky.
So let's back up and I'll tell you what's
going on.
Earlier this week, a Florida judge decided
that the CDC had overstepped its authority
with the masks on planes, and we call it masks
on planes, but it's like masks on on mass
transit regulated by the federal government.
But let's call it masks on planes.
The argument was CDC overstepped its boundaries,
and the argument made by the judge in her
decision was that the CDC is allowed to put
in place guidelines for the sanitation of
airplanes and that a mask on a person is not
really about sanitation on airplanes.
Now you could argue, well, you prevent needing
to sanitize the seats if people wear masks
and they don't put germs on the seats.
It starts to become a semantic thing.
But one of the notable aspects about the decision
was that argument could have been made at
any time during the pandemic, and it was made
by a judge now with just like 10 days left
until most likely the masks would be coming
off anyway, although we're not totally sure.
Earlier yesterday, Joe Biden was asked should
people still be wearing masks on planes?
And the Republican Party and others made a
big deal out of this answer, which Joe Biden
gave to
Speaker 2: continue to wear masks on planes?
That's up to them,
Speaker 1: that's up to them saying that is
a personal decision, it's an individual decision.
It's not for the government to tell people
what to do.
And then moments later, the Department of
Justice has appealed the federal ruling on
the transportation mask mandate, CNN and others
reporting the Justice Department Wednesday
appeal the ruling by a federal judge that
struck down the mask mandate for mass transportation
following a recommendation by the CDC.
It is the Siddiqui's continuing assessment
that at this time, an order requiring masking
in indoor transportation remains necessary
for public health.
They will monitor.
They will appeal.
There is a court decision that is ultimately
coming forward, so let's talk through the
different aspects of this.
Some are focusing on the Biden administration.
The left hand doesn't know what the right
hand is doing, Joe said.
It's a personal decision, and yet his DOJ
is appealing.
I actually don't think that's a that's a problem
in any way.
We've said before when it was Trump trying
to direct the DOJ on what to do, we would
say Trump should have no involvement with
what the DOJ does, who would investigates
what it does.
It should be just up to the DOJ.
So it's a good thing that Joe Biden gave us
his opinion.
Well, right now it's an individual decision
because at the time it was and separately.
As is supposed to happen at the end of the
day, the CDC, in consultation with the DOJ,
have said We still want this and we believe
that legally we have a case of the DOJ is
appealing.
I don't have any issue with that.
And Republicans have been saying, Oh, it's
it's chaos.
Joe says one thing.
Do you know this is happening as it should?
Joe Biden gave his opinion.
The DOJ is making its decision in consultation
with the CDC, and they will carry forward
a legal argument as to why the masks should
remain at which is their opinion.
Now what is the risk to the DOJ doing this,
particularly when the mask mandate may have
been ending on May 3rd anyway?
We don't know that for sure.
Originally, the mask mandate was through April
18th.
There was an extension through May 3rd.
Cases are actually rising now 25 30 percent.
It's not clear whether medically it makes
sense to get rid of masks on planes, but it
seemed politically it was likely coming to
an end on May 3rd anyway.
What's the risk to doing this?
While the risk is, imagine that the DOJ DOJ
fights this as full throated Li as they can,
and they don't get the masks put back on.
That could then serve as really powerful and
destructive precedent in the future.
Imagine we get the next, the next wave, you
know, call it the whatever, whatever wave
the sigma wave and its more contagious than
ever, its more deadly than ever.
And it would be appropriate to say masks have
to be on at airports and on planes.
If this decision doesn't go the DOJ's way,
there may be a total inability to put in place
a mask mandate when it's like really needed
right now.
It's like probably a good idea, but let's
admit, maybe we did leave it up to people
to decide.
We could have a situation in six months, in
12 months where it's like, Wow, we we absolutely
need masks on planes, and there might be no
way to get it done because of the decision
that might be forthcoming here.
So that's the that's the legal and political
risk.
It also would just look bad if you know, Hero
Trump appointed thirty five year old female
judge prevails over Garland and the DOJ.
It just looks bad politically.
And so that is the risk, and we won't know
for a little bit what happens, but that is
what's going on